welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Sarah Brinegar a visiting scholar
who's at Yale as the rice fellow in the
European studies council her research
interests include the history of the
Soviet Union Imperial Russia the late
ottoman empire and imperial germany
today we'll talk with Professor brinegar
about the politics of oil in the
formation of the Soviet Union welcome
professor brinegar Thank You Mara let's
begin with an overview of your book
project tell us about it sure so the
book project is a revision of my
dissertation I'm titling it right now
binding the periphery oil and state
building in the Soviet caucuses and the
project looks at the way that the Soviet
government was dependent on oil in the
weight of that dependency sir led led to
different policy outcomes and shaped the
way that they were able to construct
this state in this early period okay and
I do this sort of at with the actual
military intervention of the the Red
Army into Azerbaijan which is the area
that I focus on and its capital baku
which was the largest oil center in the
russian empire and i look at the way
they rebuild the industry and sort of
all the whole process it goes into this
so the politics that surround it where
you get money where you get capital
resources and how this affects not just
the military campaign but also literally
on the ground and in Baku and also in
the capitals and then I trace it through
its role in foreign policy and the way
that they try to use it to gain
diplomatic ties and different foreign
trade contracts which is not very
successful and then they sort of pivot
and I look at this pivot to a much more
practical on the ground collaborations
with fixers and sort of other some
unsavory types and also setting up a
loyal companies and and the way that
they use these other means to establish
ties okay and what led you to be
interested in this particular topic yeah
that is like most things has has a bit
of a roundabout story I actually started
getting interested in this in this topic
first in Azerbaijan and then in oil they
sort of came separately in 2003 so quite
a while ago now I was in Russia on a
language study and I went to cuz on
which is the capital of an autonomous
republic within the Russian Federation
tatarstan and I went to a school play
and it was in Qatar and I just thought
what what is this or what or what is
this other experience it is a Russia
that didn't know anything about so I
thought I really want to do a project on
the Soviet experience from a non Russian
point of view what was it what was it
like what did it what how was this
different or the same from what was
happening with much more familiar story
and I ended up doing that in my master's
degree I went and looked at the
revolution the Russian Revolution of
1917 from the vantage point of the
Caucasus and from azerbaijan and decided
to pursue that in my PhD and during my
language training for that for us or by
shawnee i was in baku for a summer this
is several years later um and I just
looked around and I saw oil everywhere
and I just thought this is interesting
there's something going on here because
it wasn't just that there was oil and
you there was oil and you it was an oil
city but it seems to be embedded
embedded everywhere and everything was
sponsored by BP or another oil company
it was just really interesting so I
thought I would just sort of do some
background reading and look it up and
kind of then move on with the project
that had been working on and that's not
what happened at all I realized that
there wasn't a lot of information for me
there was almost nothing in English and
even on the 1920s 1930s there was just
startling lea little even in Russian so
I thought oh wow this is this is
something
I can work with I can find out what's
going on okay so you're obviously fluent
in Russian yeah yeah so I was going to
see how so how did you do the
methodology then yeah so it's it's
pretty standard historical archival work
so I did a lot of work first in in
Azerbaijan which was really great where
I got to work with the state oil company
archives and this is something that I
realized is actually a big benefit of
doing work in where everything is
nationalized because the company
archives were also part of the State
Archives so I got some really rich
sources that are sometimes when were
difficult to get from private companies
um so did some work their work in
libraries and then again went to went to
Russia and did some more archival work
there and kind of went through their
public libraries and hunted down some
sources and so it's really most of it
most of its archival there's also some
newspapers and more and more popular
accounts as well so what are some of
your findings well I think the the most
basic one that sounds kind of obvious
but actually wasn't is that oil was
really important there is a view that it
wasn't important in fact the much of the
secondary literature especially the
Soviet literature that i came across is
all saying the oil didn't matter wasn't
important and why do you think that is i
think that it wasn't important
economically in the way that we tend to
associate oil now and we look at the oil
curse and oil resources and all these
ways that oil money drives things but i
think that in this context it wasn't the
oil money I think it was oil first oil
as a resource which is really sore
literally just fueling the feeling
economy fueling Red Army providing
kerosene because it's a different kind
of industry in 1920 then is today is
very different the industry that we see
today is much more like a post-world war
two phenomenon so at that time Russia is
still
still very poor mostly dependent on
kerosene and these kinds of things so
the big exports and super big
moneymakers would would be more grain in
these kinds of issues so there's a
fixation on on that in the literature
and not on oil and i think that i found
that oil actually especially in this
1920 1922 very early very formative
period just has an outsized place in
both domestic and foreign policy but
also beyond its use as a commodity it's
also its use in terms of trying to
negotiate on the world stage trying to
set a place for this a new radical state
through reestablishing basic
partnerships and business partnerships
and things that had been severed during
the war that it was through these other
channels the oil was very important and
remained so for it for quite a while out
of that time period ok so um what was
the role of oil in the formation of the
soviet union well um that is a big
question and it changes I think in the
beginning years it's that role of
literally as a resource as energy oil as
energy it's internally for the country
they weren't really exporting it
anywhere at that point or other where
other parts of the Soviet Union were
shipping it to yeah that's a good
question actually it is important
primarily as hard currency early on so
once the basic needs of the military are
met the military and actually that the
railroad some of the Russian railroads
were already running on oil products
once those basic needs were met then the
remainder of that was sent abroad for
hard currency and then that hard
currency is in turn busted into the
economy and in many ways it was used to
rebuild the coal industry which is an
interesting dynamic and actually looked
very counterintuitive and a lot of
people thought for a long time that this
was evidence of Russian backwardness
right the Soviets didn't understand the
economy they didn't understand how to
use anything but in fact they were
trying
to use these the hard currency from
things like oil in order to create a
domestic market for coal because the
economy was shattered the whole country
was shattered so it was using it in this
way that was not immediately obvious to
outsiders but why call in that oil coal
is cheaper it's much cheaper it has a
different kind of infrastructure and I
think the other big issue is it oil is
very capital intensive for one thing
machinery is very expensive equipment is
very expensive going through a big
technological boom at this time and they
didn't have access to or the means to
get this new capital infrastructure
which is something that they do start
doing but also they came to the
conclusion that oil made the selenium
more vulnerable that it was actually a
liability and it was a liability
primarily because of where it was
located it's located right on the border
region with Turkey and Iran and at that
time the British were very active in
that area and they looked at it as
making the borders much more insecure
and much more vulnerable to foreign
occupation which had happened several
times over the course of World War one
alright so ultimately what do you
conclude I ultimately conclude that
there is a lot of work left to be done
in this area I think it's a really
exciting area and I think that there are
route there's room for a lot more work
and a lot more scholars than just you
happily have some colleagues in this
area and that it is important it is
something that we need to go back in we
need to understand more of because it
explains a lot about the way that the
economy is built at that time period but
also going into World War two what sorts
of challenges the Soviet Union face and
didn't face because of the way the
industry had developed and I think it
also tells us a lot about the way that
oil works outside of the capitalist
system that they were in sort of a
costume to this idea of oil and the oil
curse and I think there's a very
different dynamic in the Soviet Union
that really needs to be
explored because I think the story is a
very different one very good very
interesting thank you very much for
being here with us today great thank you
for more information about professor
Brinegar and her work please visit our
website at macmillan report yale edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at gale
you